moscow's highest court has rejected an
appeal against the arrest of a woman
charged with a bomb attack that killed
an influential Russian military blogger
26 year old Daria tripova is accused of
using an explosive concealed and a
statuette to kill vladen tatasky in a
cafe in Saint Petersburg tatasky was an
Ardent supporter of the war in Ukraine
who filed reports in the fighting from
the front lines
we can speak now to the journalist Yulia
chapovolova who joins me now from Moscow
Yulia what happened in court today
so as we understand Daria Trevor
will remain in jail as the Moscow city
court has made a decision to leave her
behind bars at the Detention Center
recognizing the legitimacy of her arrest
the court was holding a close hearing on
their appeal filed earlier this month by
Daria's defense team at the beginning of
the meeting she said that she regretted
that the tragedy had taken place and
wished a speedy recovery to the victims
of the blast she didn't say though
whether she pleaded guilty or not
tripova is accused of committing a
terrorist attack uh you're right that
killed military blog and a very staunch
supporter of Russia's military operation
in Ukraine vladland tatasky whose real
name was Maxim for mean and he died on
April the second following an explosion
at a cafe in the center of Saint
Petersburg where he was meeting
his supporters and social media follows
40 other people were wounded back then
as we know a statue had given to
tatarsky as a gift exploded in his hands
and according to investigators it was
brought to the cafe by Daria trepova who
is convicted now she's a 26 year old
woman from Saint Petersburg who was
living in Moscow at the time of the
terror attack and she was detained the
very next day and arrested for two
months Elia from what I understand Daria
is not the only suspect in this case how
is the criminal investigation going
um we have the information that Daria
was cooperating with the investigation
while being held at the detention center
and we also of course know that the FSB
immediately blamed the Ukrainian special
services for the attack right after it
happened they also named an alleged
organizer of the explosion a Ukrainian
citizen who presumably arrived in Russia
from Ukraine via Latvia he handed over
the figurine to Daria Trevor using a
delivery service and it was said that
the next day after the explosion the man
left Russia for turkey via Armenia the
FSB also blamed members of the
anti-corruption fund founded by Russia's
prominent opposition activist and
politician Alexei navalny who's now
serving his nine-year prison term in a
Russian jail so the FSB claimed that
Daria committed a terrorist attack
inspired by by repeated calls by the
leaders of the anti-corruption fund and
so the fund obviously uh denied those
allegations according to them the
Russian authorities want to place
additional blame on Alexei navalny and
accuse him of terrorism and extremism
the accusations that can prolong his
prison term Ukraine also denied its
involvement calling the attack domestic
terrorism so we're here following the
developments in Moscow thank you for
that journalist Julia shapovalova
joining us there from Moscow